en el vídeo anterior empezamos a pensar
en cómo podemos usar una recta de
regresión y en particular la pendiente
de la recta de regresión con base en
datos muestrales es decir cómo podemos
usar esta información para hacer una
inferencia acerca de la pendiente
verdadera de la recta de regresión
poblacional en este vídeo vamos a pensar
en cuáles son las condiciones para la
inferencia cuando estamos trabajando con
rectas de regresión déjame anotarlo
vamos a pensar en las condiciones para
la inferencia y estas van a ser de
ciertas maneras similares a las
condiciones para la inferencia que
pensamos cuando hacíamos pruebas de
hipótesis e intervalos de confianza para
medias y proporciones pero esta vez
tendremos algunas condiciones nuevas
ahora bien para ayudarnos a recordar
estas condiciones podemos pensar en el
acrónimo
observé que de manera obvia formamos la
palabra línea y esto es muy útil porque
recuerda que estamos trabajando con
regresiones lineales la l de aquí
representa la palabra lineal aquí la
condición es que la relación real entre
las poblaciones que representan las
variables x y james sean de hecho una
relación lineal déjame escribirlo una
relación lineal real entre x y de ahora
viene en muchas ocasiones tendremos que
suponer que esto es cierto más aún
cuando lo veas en un examen por ejemplo
en un examen ap
seguramente dirán oye supón que esta
condición es cierta o que se cumple
otras veces te dirán supón que todas las
condiciones son ciertas o que se cumplen
quizás sólo quieran que sepas que
existen estas condiciones sin embargo es
importante pensar en esta condición ya
que si la relación que observamos no
fuera lineal entonces quizás algunas de
tus inferencias
podrían no ser tan robustas la siguiente
es una condición que hemos visto antes
cuando hablamos de condiciones generales
para la inferencia hablábamos de la
condición de independencia y hay un par
de formas de pensar acerca de ella o las
observaciones individuales son
independientes entre sí por lo que
podríamos estar mostrando con reemplazo
o podemos pensar en la regla del 10% que
usamos antes cuando pensamos acerca de
la condición de independencia para
proporciones y para medias en donde
tenemos que sentirnos seguros de que el
tamaño de nuestra muestra no es mayor
que el 10% del tamaño de la población
bien la siguiente condición es la
condición de normalidad de la cual
también ya hemos hablado cuando
trabajamos con diferencias para
proporciones y para medias sin embargo
significa algo ligeramente más
sofisticado cuando trabajamos con
regresiones lineales aunque en algunas
ocasiones nos digan de antes
manu que esta condición se cumple es más
déjame dibujar por aquí una recta de
regresión para que veas a qué me refiero
y esta vez lo haré con perspectiva es
decir agregar una tercera dimensión
supongamos que este es el eje x y este
es el eje y y que la recta de regresión
poblacional verdadera se ve algo así y
lo que nos dice la condición de
normalidad es que dada a cualquier x en
la población verdadera la distribución
de 10 que esperaríamos se distribuye de
manera normal déjame dibujar una
distribución normal para la que es esto
cuando tenemos una x dada por lo tanto
esta será la distribución normal aquí y
ahora para esta otra x de aquí también
esperaríamos una distribución normal así
que dada una x la distribución para
leyes
debe de ser normal una vez más muchas
veces te dirán que suponga que se
cumplen esta condición porque por lo
menos en una clase de introducción a la
estadística
a ser un poco difícil averiguar esto por
tu cuenta la siguiente condición está
relacionada con eso y es la idea de
tener varianzas equiparables
pero para que sirva para nuestro
acrónimo le llamaremos equiparables
varianzas lo que nos dice es que dada
una x cada una de estas distribuciones
normales debe de tener la misma
dispersión así que puedes llamarle la
misma varianza o puedes pensarlo como
una desviación estándar igual así que
por ejemplo para esta cierta x dada si
de repente tuviéramos una varianza mucho
más pequeña es decir una varianza que
hiciera que se viera algo así entonces
ya no se cumplirían las condiciones para
la inferencia y por último pero no menos
importante esto lo hemos visto en varias
ocasiones tenemos la condición de
aleatoriedad
y esta condición nos habla de que los
datos que obtenemos deben de venir de
una muestra aleatoria bien diseñada o de
algún tipo de experimento aleatorio y
esta condición la hemos visto en todas
las condiciones para la inferencia que
hemos estudiado ok vamos a dejarlo hasta
aquí es bueno saber esto porque va a
aparecer en algunos exámenes pero en
muchas ocasiones cuando se trata de
resolver ejercicios en tus clases de
introducción a la estadística te dirán
que supongan que se satisfacen o que se
cumplen estas condiciones o te
preguntarán cuáles son las condiciones
para la inferencia sin embargo en
realidad no te van a poner a probarlas
por ejemplo la condición de normalidad o
la condición de equiparables varianzas
ya que eso sería demasiado para una
clase introductoria bueno me despido nos
vemos el siguiente vídeo